all right here's the first story we got
this from the post millennial breaking
Sam Smith stages satanic Grammy
performance with strippers and devil
horns Petrus danced in the cage Smith
wore devil horns while dancers in long
red robes with straight uh hair fond
around him in a ritual Circle all right
I'm gonna say it first off and and and
first and foremost yeah I don't I don't
really care about artistic faux satanic
whatever but there's more to the story
than just a performance of the Grammys I
think it was uh Brett dasovic from pop
culture crisis was mentioning that
Marilyn Manson did stuff like this in
the 90s it's not shocking to be edgy and
be like ooh I'm gonna wear devil horns
but there's a couple things about it
notably and we have this tweet
brought to you by Pfizer Let's uh let's
let's play it so you've got you know Kim
Petras and Sam Smith you know cheering
and getting some award and then this
[Music]
is
it just really feels like
um a trifecta of right wing talking
points happening all at the same time
you have an un the song is called Unholy
satanic imagery brought to you by Pfizer
and one of the individuals uh Kim Petras
is famous I believe I believe Kim is
from Germany and is famous for appearing
in a documentary requesting a sex change
operation at the age of 13 or 14 and
actually having received it as a minor
so
all of these things together we're not
just talking about an artistic show
that's meant to be shocking and edgy
there actually are elements that many
people are shocked by but I don't know
what do you guys think is this uh I
don't know people overreacting or is it
just I don't think brought to you by
Pfizer is an overreaction that's weird
man corporate I mean this is is far away
from Rock and Roll as you can possibly
get as corporate Pfizer like corporate
money drug drug
they made 50 what do they make like 50
billion dollars 100 billion or something
in profit I don't know what was the
number
I don't know was it that much Pfizer
yeah like one year yeah or maybe in the
past two years I made like 100 billion
or something you have guaranteed
government contracts that's basically
free money John you've been to the
Grammys yeah multiple times you say yeah
I've been nominated for nine Grammys the
house throughout my career how many
satanic performances did you see uh to
date I've done a total of zero satanic
performances so I guess I'm not the cool
kid anymore yeah I think it's to see
this sponsored by Pfizer brought to you
by Pfizer I thought oh there's the drugs
and the sex drugs and rock and roll
maybe that's what that is just different
kind of drugs yeah the kind that you
have to take that nobody knows what it's
going to do well you ever hear that like
I don't know old Trope of the hippie
becoming the business person when they
get all like the Boomers we're all young
and wild and crazy and then they become
suits later on I mean I'm wondering if
the real story there is that the hippie
State hippies and suit stayed suits and
we just assumed that because Boomers
were hippies Boomers be like this
hippies became suits or whatever but
it's like it's just a funny thought that
sex drugs and rock and roll goes from
being in the alley in the gutter and
just STDs doing hard drugs and playing
music and just degeneracy to on a stage
in a multi-million dollar a billion
dollar industry with choreography and
performances and pharmaceutical drugs
yes not street drugs what I got is this
doesn't even really satanic this is like
if satanics like Ozzy Osbourne chewing
the head off of a live bat that was an
accident yeah it was an accident but he
did and there's blood on stage maybe not
satanic Ozzy maybe not people pouring
blood on themselves on stage like dark
you know that's a little more satanic
this is like the image of Satanism it's
not even real Satanism it's it's all foe
like they put on red and they have fire
behind them but it's like supposed to be
it's called it's even called Unholy like
it's supposed to be satanic I don't know
I don't know maybe maybe the singer who
is advocating for child sex change
surgery is the thing that's Sam Smith
I'm just gonna say Sam Smith ripped off
Tom Petty with that well back down Won't
You Stand My Ground that song that he
did
yeah Tom Petty ended up his ended up
making uh residuals off that I think he
passed part of the whole performance is
that it's so surface level right like
truly provocative things your audience
is going to stand up and applaud
afterwards so great good job like this
was no Matt they could have done
anything they could have gone out there
and done nothing stood still and the
audience would be like wow
groundbreaking amazing performance so
glad that you guys did that uh I think
part of the I think you're totally right
it's not even a a very uh original uh
depiction of like Satan and like
semi-anti-christian imagery I think it's
sort of cheap and done to make it seem
like we are still counter-cultural but
really they're not they are the
mainstream supported by a major drug
company coming out and uh promoting
talking points that are more and more
part of the mainstream narrative like
yes everything we're doing is okay it's
it's like they want to be edgy and they
can't anymore you know you know what I
I'm just not into is it seems like the
principle commentary in all this is that
the performance was satanic and I'm just
like okay you know if you want to talk
about Sam Smith non-binary child sex
change operations Pfizer being the
sponsor but let's talk about massive
multi multi-billion dollar corporations
sponsoring satanic shows that I can get
but it seems like most people are just
saying like look they wore devil horns
and they were dancing in red I can't
believe it this is pure evil and I'm
like well what what about it because I
mean are we gonna seriously we'll go
back and talk about any any death metal
band or like black metal in Scandinavia
and all the dark demonic imagery they
they use I do like there was more
backlash when uh Miley Cyrus came out
and like twerked on someone at one of
the award shows right that's arguably
more satanic being sexual and people
were more upset about you heard more of
both sides being like she's so liberated
that's inappropriate whatever this it's
just like yes we're completely falling
on party lines right there are the
people who are annoyed by it are annoyed
and the people who like it like it I
mean there's no Nuance to it anymore if
they had if it had been green light all
green and they were wearing Shamrock
cats no one would mention Satanism and
it would be called don't even question
why I was called on holy so it's like
the the it's like the Visage of of evil
just to like sell tickets they're like
look how dark yeah look how provocative
we're flies are exactly it would have
been it would have been an awesome show
if they were green with Gemini cats that
have been I'd have been into it then the
Irish Community is like take it back
immediately what's wrong with us well
the whole point the whole point you
spend millions and millions of dollars
for visual
visual elements to music
is to sell more music it's to sell music
sell tickets it's it's to push the music
further like you got a song you want to
put a great video behind it so more
people see it and hopefully love the
song and it becomes your thing and and
people sit around and have really big
meetings around really big tables like
this at record labels and they spend
tens of millions of dollars behind a lot
of these artists all for marketing of
the music of that artist and marketing
the artist so more people will want to
consume that content so when you look at
this performance on the Grammys they're
sitting there going what's going to make
the most people
like this artist like this music you
know come to come to the party here I
know what let's just simulate hell
on stage and then let's tag it with
Pfizer which is the biggest cuss word in
America right now
this is the pitch so what does that what
does that say about what they think
about the audience that this is what
they're going to pour their money into
for the visual backups of the music yeah
they probably think we're really
gullible and we'll bite and start
talking about it on TV exactly and we
did I did I wanted but that cuts both
ways because you want people to like it
we don't like it we're seeing it we're
repulsed by it but you know this is what
happens with with everything culture War
related a lot of these big companies
know uh I'll give you an example when uh
Jim Jordan was talking we'll get super
political Jim Jordan's talking with uh
Chuck Todd and meet on Meet the Press
and he says you know with with Donald
Trump you had the Secret Service
protecting these documents you had them
locked you had the doj actually came in
and put the lock on it with Joe Biden
they're stored in a garage Chuck Todd
immediately comes the defense of Joe
Biden despite the fact that any sane
reasonable thinking person is going to
be like what the you talking about like
Chuck Todd's like no no no Trump did it
Trump did it and it's like he just laid
out for you the details of the story
you're not refuting them you're just
saying yeah well Trump is bad what
they're doing is
20 2012 they had 39 million viewers the
most they've ever had the year before
was like 29 typically averaged around 27
28 million viewers then there was this
massive drop-off from 2019 of like 18
million viewers to 8 million then in 20
in 2021 I think 2020 to 2021 then in
2022 they had
I think about 8.93 million they have no
audience nobody watches
they'll take anything they can get
they're they are so desperate for
attention and I imagine there's probably
some executive or somebody associated
with the Grammys and they're sitting
there saying like guys
we lost 60 of our viewers we're dead in
the water what do we do and they were
like people aren't going to want to
watch shows like this we need
controversy we need to piss people off
and here's the hope
get a bunch of conservatives angry and
at the very least you will rescue a
liberal audience so they start posting
stuff like this hoping that shows like
this generate rage but not that we will
watch it that the tribalists in the cult
will say well we're big fans of the
Grammys and then they will start
endorsing it and the Machine will then
prop up the Grammys I think to your
point uh Beyonce won I think she just
became the most grammy-winning artist of
all time at this Grammys right Beyonce
is one of those things that like she's
one of these artists that like can do no
wrong and people even if her music is
bad even if she's not interesting even
if she's involved with Scandal even if
her husband or her sister is filmed
hitting her husband in an elevator like
she survives anything she's bulletproof
so to be like and we're bringing back
Beyonce who can who you will rally
around no matter what is sort of this
way to keep an audience that you know
they're not trying to win us over
they're trying to win their base back
over uh and I mean Beyonce won for uh
Renaissance right this is like just
after she performed in um
in the Middle East in a country that's
completely anti-lgbtq even though her
her album is supposed to be based off
the black LGBT experience like it it
doesn't make any sense they don't have
to follow their own rules they just have
to bring out the figureheads that they
like and know that you'll cheer for them
because it's making someone else angry
someone you don't like angry I didn't
know Beyonce performed until just now I
care so little about this I'm a musician
and I don't even I talk to me this I I
credit all of this knowledge to pop
culture crisis I go on and they teach me
about these things uh I knew she was
performing because an influencer that I
follow on occasion was at this big
private Resort opening and she was
performing for like some crazy amount of
money but what happened to music John in
the last decade
well uh that's a great question I just
here here and you're right about what
they're what they're trying to do is to
you said Salvage what's left of their
liberal base that's a good way to put it
but then I have to think well what's
wrong with that base
that that would Salvage them well I
think I mean you understand that's how
regular people look at like I'm a dad I
got two sons you know
they can't I'm not gonna let them watch
the Grammys I mean one of my sons caught
a little piece of it said Dad it looks
like they're all in hell
and I said no we're in hell for having
to watch it let you know change the
channel I mean he was going what am I
looking at you know a little kid who
loves music and he's seeing that go on
like like Sam Smith is being devoured by
demons on the stage when they push him
down at the end like they're eating him
or whatever that was supposed to be and
then brought to you by Pfizer my son
goes
the vaccine company's buying this I went
yeah he's 11. well so it used to be that
there were very few channels cable TV
didn't get really that much ratings
because it cost money and so the Grammys
probably got 30 million viewers because
people turned on the TV yeah and that's
what was on everybody was talking about
it then the internet started becoming
more and more prominent YouTube videos I
remember back in the day in the early
days of YouTube you could put out a
video on these big channels we got like
a million hits because it was there was
very few there was very there was very
little content on it that was worth
watching a bunch of weird stuff like a
person filming a birthday party then all
of a sudden higher quality content but
as more and more people started to use
the internet things started decentralize
and viewers are to flatten out so I
remember talking to some big YouTubers
who were like you know we used to get a
million million and a half now we get 50
to 100K and I'm like well yeah now
you're competing with 10 100 times as
many people so the ratings for everybody
drops and what ends up happening is
extremism and drama and uh hard hard
like view politics are your path to
getting clicks so the thing about news
is that everybody knows everybody knows
everything right the balloon happens
someone posts on Twitter there's a
balloon over Montana instantly everybody
knows so there's no there's no news
channel you can't make a news show and
be like ladies and gentlemen there's a
balloon over Montana thing like dude I
heard that on Twitter instantly you're
telling me nothing so what ends up
happening is that news programs become
people programs where they talk about
their view of the news like what we're
doing quite literally but more
importantly they realize there's more
views in talking about personal issues
so here's what ends up happening with
something like this
in my view
they know they're never getting back
those 39 million viewers because that
was a captive audience
but if they're going to get back any
amount of viewers they need to create a
tribe that will latch onto them do this
and you will get Hardline hard politic
woke liberal people who will defend you
and watch just because you're on their
side that's how it works
so I think if this is the path things
are going part of me wonders if these
platforms will die off because I'm
hoping you know here's my gamble human
nature is some people may want the shot
content the the tribalism and the drama
and some people might want the
conversation and I'm hoping the
conversation the ideas are actually
what's going to win but I gotta be
honest I'm not the most confident
considering that these companies keep
doing stuff like this they're not
backing down maybe they'll fail and got
a business and will all be proven right
or maybe what's going to happen is
you're going to find that humans really
do just want to consume gutter trash
Coliseum content watch the Lions rip
apart the Gladiators yeah okay uh you're
talking about the Grammys the people
that the company that runs that might go
bankrupt at some point is that the
company we're talking about their views
are down from two years ago by 60 some
odd percent it's no longer that we have
to wait a year to hear what like 30
people think is the best song on Earth
you know some awards ceremony used to be
now the Grammys should have their own
YouTube Network or their own network
where every week you go there and
there's new videos and songs on
grammy.com or whatever they should pivot
but like waiting for the Oscars to show
to tell me what was good I already know
I saw it I don't need it and the word
shows used to have this exclusive
exclusivity to celebrities right like
they're coming down the red carpet and
what are you wearing and who do they
bring as their date but now you see all
of that on social media any celebrity
who's appearing at this event has some
sort of social media following so some
of the mystery of you know being removed
when we didn't have social media when
you were waiting you had to watch the
broadcast to get all of these details
about these people that you look up to
or you're interested in or you're
following or whatever like you can get
that a drop of a hat now so you're right
like the Grammys and all the other award
shows need to adapt after die because I
don't think anyone looks I mean very few
people I definitely don't look to these
institutional award shows to say like ah
yes I you have recommended a good song
to me I will listen to it now you know
like it it doesn't mean anything anymore
you're more likely to get a reference
from someone you know personally and
then you don't have this Elite space
where you're saying oh well I get to see
the celebrities live you see them all
the time they're Overexposed on social
media thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time